in this time things are changing
dramatically
my own view in the united states it is
the inequality that has
led us here uh it isn't and certainly
the elite have
benefited from that but we also
have in the u.s a political class that
is completely out of touch
in my view with the american people anna
and an ethos uh in washington
that is very power centric fueled by
legally corrupt money uh
that have in their main
in their main goal is to stay in power
uh and and i've seen it and this isn't
the last three years i've watched this
grow over the course of
certainly the last 20 or so when i was
in washington
uh and i think that is at the core
of the resentment uh
on the part of the people united states
the disappearance of what we used to
call
the american dream where everybody sort
of had an equal shot
and the complete lack of accountability
we've heard accountability multiple
times
here the complete lack of accountability
on the part of anybody in a position of
power
you